gamer schminken haben glatte haut und
sind sozial völlig unfähig wochen das
ganz anders um das sind alles vorteile
ergebnis natürlich auch wie spielt aber
für die meisten zocker gilt wie bin
gesund und zwar besonders und dafür
legen jedenfalls wissenschaftliche
studien jetzt in science fiction von der
gamescom zu kommen
mehr als 300.000 gaming fans werden
wieder die gamescom bevölkerung was
auffällt sie sehen erfreulich gesund aus
und dafür gibt es eben einen einfachen
grund
gaming ist gesund aber erstmals eine
offizielle entwarnung der gewalt spiel
gespielt wird nicht krank oder
entwickelt sich irgendwie abnormal ein
amerikanischer forschungsteam hat
letztes jahr mit einer sehr großen
anzahl von kindern nämlich und zurück zu
den 1000 untersucht ob es
verhaltensstörungen bei ihnen oder
vermehrt depressionen gibt die gewalt
spiele zocken er ergebnis es gibt keine
signifikanten unterschiede zu kindern
wie zb eher harmlose spiele spielen also
schädlich sind games immer nicht aber
sie sind eben sogar fünf beispiel ein
super mario 64
hier untersuchte das max-planck-institut
die gehirnentwicklung während einer
zweimonatigen phase bei den
teilnehmenden erwachsenen die ja
eigentlich schon ein aufwendiges gehirn
haben müssen
rufen sie hirnregionen die für das
gaming benutzt wurden und dass innerhalb
von zwei monaten erfahren regionen die
für die navigation im dreidimensionalen
raum erinnerungen strategisches plan und
feinmotorische fähigkeiten befasst waren
denn dieser könne weiß wie bei besser
sehen durch ego shooter wie mcmaster
university in kanada wie erwachsene die
nach der erkrankung mit dem grauen stadt
trotz operation nicht mehr so sehen
konnten medal of honor zocken ergebnis
nach 40 stunden spielzeit in vier wochen
berichteten die versuch teilnehmerinnen
und teilnehmer deutlich besser sehen zu
können
beispiel 3 besser sehen für alle auch
generell verbessert dass vielen von ego
shootern klassen bavariae von der
university of rochester in den usa und
ihr team wiesen 2009 verschiedene
gruppen mit testversuchen jeweils 50
stunden an return am 14
call of duty 2 und sie sind diejenigen
die super soften verbesserten hiervon
57 hintergrund die eu sicherstellen
extrem hohe anforderungen an das auge
und das hören da ständig der gesamte
bildschirm auf veränderung und bewegung
hin aberkannt werden muss
das schulter sehen offenbar und führt zu
den deutlich verbesserten fähigkeiten
bei den personen die die sind zwei
gespielten partie übrigens mit beispiel
wir sie hoben sollen mehr zocken ein
forschungsteam vom beth israel medical
center in new york untersuchte die
fähigkeiten konnte rogan und zerrungen
und franz warten werde heraus klinik
nämlich wie in ihrem eifer games krisen
operiert ist in über 20 prozent
schneller und machten bis zu 37 prozent
weniger fehler im western beispiel fünf
was haben ex fußballer philipp lahm
kabarettist eckart von hirschhausen und
der frühere aok chef jürgen graalmann
gemeinsam sie haben in einen games
publisher für senioren investiert retro
brain als die firma und sie entwickelt
viele für senioren und seniorinnen aber
nicht dass ich einfach nur so sondern
bei dem jede gegründet werden jetzt
einige beispiele
die firma hat spiele entwickelt die die
entwicklung der demenz deutlich
verlangsamen sollen und vor allem auch
die motorischen fähigkeiten fördern
durch werden stürzen verhindert und die
seniorinnen und senioren sollen länger
selbstständig bleiben zurzeit werden die
rentner games von der berliner humboldt
universität untersucht ich bin mal
gespannt und halten euch natürlich dazu
auf dem laufenden wenn ihr zu diesem und
zu anderen geben kann wieder verpassen
wollt dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs
auge und vergesst nicht gehen
genau auf die glocke hier geht es weiter
mit big bang urknall aufgedeckt wie
immer extrem spannend wachstum und
ansonsten getan
dapd